and the winner of the m2 air is apple's
new m2 laptops have a super power that
nobody is talking about and i'm using it
right now well today we are going to
show you exactly how that is how i came
across wanting to test it what it does
and how it absolutely blew my mind now
with that we are going to be choosing
the winner of our m2 macbook air
giveaway in this video in real time live
on screen so make sure you guys stick
around and you guys see if you are the
one who won it all started out when i
started testing the m2 macbook air about
a week ago the biggest question that
people had was how bad does the fanless
m2 air thermal throttle compare to the
m2 pro that does have a fan right out of
the gate we started noticing
temperatures like 104 107 and even 108
degrees shortly after we started our
very first run of cinebench even then
our first run was quite impressive
compared to the m2 macbook pro
just because the temps stayed high and
the frequency stayed high just dropping
a tiny bit resulting in pretty good
performance but then we decided to do a
longer run and take a look at the cpu
wattage and frequencies as the test
continued and what really surprised me
was how much the wattage dropped after
the temps started to get way too hot for
too long and then dropping down a bit to
control uh the heat now that is normal
but what wasn't normal or what was very
interesting was the scores that we were
getting our first run was using over 20
watts to achieve that great score
but then we dropped down to 10 watts and
the performance didn't drop that much
all while using half the power or even
less than that and having much lower
temperatures now if you remember our m1
versus m2 macbook pro comparison we
found that the m2 chip uses 33 more
power to gain only 13 more performance
so we ended up calling it the m 1.5
instead of the m2 because it uses a lot
more power to gain a little bit more
frequency to give us a little bit more
power while having a lot more heat and
more power usage which is exactly what
happens when you overclock a system and
because of that and it's single fan if
you push it hard like we did when we
compared it to the 14 inch macbook pro
it can absolutely thermal throttle reach
those high temperatures and then shut
the power down to the cpu and the gpu
in order to cool itself down and then
ramp up once again with those crazy
power usages and temps in order to keep
rolling unlike the m2 macbook air which
doesn't have a fan and they end up
clocking it down so those performance
cores are essentially the same but
overclocked but what isn't the same with
the m2 chip are the efficiency cords and
nobody is really focusing on them they
are brand new they are larger they are
more powerful and they are more
efficient so after seeing that cinebench
run at 10 watts i went into the settings
and i noticed something that i had to
test out and this is where the super
power comes in
i needed to check the optimized battery
charging because we needed to charge up
quickly to do a battery test and i
noticed the low power mode now this
isn't brand new it's been out for a
little while but nobody really focused
on it because with the m1 chips and the
own pros and macs they had very little
efficiency cores they were weak but the
efficiency cores in the system are much
more powerful so i had to test it out
and my mind was blown now before i show
you the real world results
that did way better than i expected let
me get vadim into here so we can give
away the m2 macbook air hey guys vadim
here and we are so close to a million
subscribers only around 2 000 away so if
you haven't subscribed click the button
down below right now yes please even if
you didn't uh do the giveaway you didn't
care about it help us out if you watch
our content and now let's give away this
brand new starlight m2 macbook air we
did not want anybody to deal with the
ssd issues so we bought one that has 512
gigs of storage so you are gonna be set
now let me explain how we're doing this
we did nine videos with this launch week
and we have them in a playlist right
here one through nine and i'm gonna
choose one of them as the video that
we're gonna use for the giveaway so
let's do that right now it is going to
be
the first video
once again one number one is excellent
that's the teardown i think it has the
most comments so we're going to be
choosing a random comment from here so
what i'll do is i'll grab the url and
i'll paste it into youtube comment
picker.com i'm going to filter the
duplicate users and let's get those
comments and it looks like we have
almost 19 000 unique comments so it's
going to choose out of that and let's go
ahead and start the raffle let's see who
it is
all right moment of truth we're rolling
oh are done
comments says thanks for the video and
the giveaway do you think he's that
young i was gonna try to read the name
again too dude imagine like a ten year
old i hope that's about it it's a
ten-year-old and he's gonna get
uh the macbook air so let's check the
link here
he's got a thousand subscribers on here
doing various videos some tech stuff uh
looks like he's in turkey
his channel's been around for a while so
it's not some
scammer or spammer that's posting let's
subscribe to him we are super excited to
get you your m2 macbook air
congratulations thank you to all the
viewers and supporters now if we for
some reason can't get a hold of him uh
then we will basically just redo the
raffle one more time in a future video
so thank you guys and let's get back
into it all right and now let me show
you what the m2 ship could do in that
low power mode both in terms of
benchmarks and real-world productivity
performance compared to itself and
windows laptops along with the power
usage the temperatures which are
shocking and
battery life starting out with a simple
geekbench 5 test you can see that it
uses about 24
watts when it is running for the
multi-core test now when i enable the
low power mode we get a peak of 7.5
watts compared to almost 24 watts and
the average cpu was at about three and a
half watts compared to 9.3 that is about
three times less power usage so what are
the results does the system get three
times slower well you probably guessed
it yourself it doesn't we got a single
core score of a thousand two hundred and
seventy six so yes that is dramatically
slower but let me show you the real
world productivity results here in a sec
and a multi-core score of 6273
so that is about 40 percent less
performance but it uses three times less
power which is insane what makes this
even crazier is that in yesterday's
video where we tested out the dell xps
13 which uses intel's 12th generation
alder lake system which is more
efficient has efficiency cores that
thing got a thousand
182 for single core on battery power so
slower than the m2 chip with that low
power mode that uses way less power this
is both with background stuff running
and apps and all that so it is slow and
as far as multi-core it got 5476
and that is using over 20 watts of power
on a battery without it being plugged in
compared to 7.5 watts on the macbook so
the macbook beats it out while using
three to five times less power
throughout this test and that shows the
true performance and efficiency of apple
silicon compared to even intel's 12th
gen processors now in that video we also
compared the battery life of the xps
compared to the macbook they both
started at 60
and after we did a few hours of running
it testing speakers some performance
tests the dell died on us and at that
same time the macbook had 40 percent
battery left over so only drained 20
compared to 60. now we have the oled
model of the dell so that does suck more
power but the battery drain was just
crazy when it was in its best
performance mode switching it to the
power saving mode does help a bit but it
makes a system way slower with a web
browsing speed of 133 which is insanely
slow and we switch it to performance it
actually goes up to about 209
so you get almost half the performance
now the m2 macbook air in that low power
mode ends up getting 222
in its low power mode
beating out the dell i7 alder lake in
its best performance mode so how is it
doing this and what about real world
productivity tasks well when you enable
it it uses all four of the efficiency
cores full blast and then it uses a tiny
bit of performance cores to give it a
little bit of an extra boost and it
clocks those down to 2 gigahertz from
the 3.5 gigahertz standard setting which
uses way less power and it's a lot more
efficient now in lightroom classic when
i was working with the photos it did a
killer job it was amazing and then when
i exported it only used about 2 watts of
power for the cpu and then about 1 watt
or so or even less for the gpu which
sounds insane that's so low and that's
true normally the cpu is using about 18
watts in the graphics about three and a
half with much higher peaks than that
which result in temperatures that reach
108 degrees
celsius using the low power mode our
hottest core reached only 51 degrees
celsius the system stayed insanely cool
now what are the results of this export
i mean you would think man we're using
so little power the thing is super cool
you don't even notice it uh it's gonna
you know sip battery it must be
extremely slow right
well that took three minutes and 25
seconds to export these 50 images
whereas the dell took three minutes and
42 seconds when it is running on battery
and that is using closer to 10 times
more
power which blows my mind now if you
turn off the low power mode and it gets
super hot use a lot more battery it will
do this task much faster on the m2
macbook air so i think it might not be
worth using it when you're exporting but
of course you could just disable that
when you're exporting for that short
burst and then enable it again if you're
just going through photos because even
in low power mode the performance is
more than enough and this leads me to
real world battery life which is the
perfect timing because dave lee just
released his video covering the
competition for the m2 macbook air and
in that video he included the xps 13
plus with the base 1080p or so display
that sips power and when it came time to
talk about battery life
this chart blew my mind once again we
have the mt macbook air that lasts about
11 hours and 15 minutes for light use
and then four hours and 16 minutes for
heavy use now personally i like to do
the mixed use charts which you guys have
seen before
but when you look at the dell
it scores 10 hours 16 minutes for light
use and that is probably in the power
savings mode that it wants to run but
only an hour and 48 minutes for heavy
use and this is
the model that has the weaker cpu
and that has that 1080p screen so our
hands-on video where the dell died so
quickly
that was true that is honest it's
terrible performance too
when you have it unplugged like that so
the m2 macbook air absolutely destroys
those laptops with way weaker processors
and worse screens in battery life while
being way better in every way but then
when you enable the low power mode and
it's using three times less power you
can get closer to that 10 hours of use
while you're doing things like video
editing photo editing and other
productivity tasks and then even for the
light usage caps the frequencies you can
get closer to 14 15 hours of use now you
might say well that is already great
what it offers out of the box that is
absolutely true but if you're somebody
that doesn't want your system to heat up
really hot you want to cap that it's
going to run insanely cool and then if
you grab your macbook and say has 20
battery life and maybe you don't have a
charger with you or you can't plug in
somewhere you can enable that and still
get better performance than the windows
competition
while having insanely great battery life
and it's just gonna last a very long
time and that wasn't available even with
the m1 series of chips but with four
really powerful new efficiency cores in
the system it makes it absolutely
amazing and this isn't only for simple
tasks i also edited 4k video with
effects added and normally when we're
exporting this we're using about 1.2
watts with a higher peak about seven and
a half and then about five watts for the
graphics which is already very low
because of apple's media engine but in
low power mode we were using half a watt
of the cpu and about 1.2 of the gpu
which is
insane and as far as the export times it
took 4 minutes and 20 seconds to export
this so still faster than real time of
five minutes compared to about two
minutes and 20 seconds when it's using
way more power so it uses five times
less power and it doesn't even take
twice as long to do that which is crazy
now what's even crazier is that the dell
xps on battery in its best performance
mode taking i don't know ten times
more power
that takes almost eight minutes in
davinci resolve to do the same task and
with that while i would probably say you
know what put into regular performance
mode when you're exporting have it be
faster and then maybe put it back uh
when you're actually editing the
timeline it can handle this playing back
perfectly while only using an average of
0.18 watts on the cpu and an average of
1.1 watt on the gpu so you can edit full
4k video with some effects granted
lighter ones nothing crazy
on low power mode and get insane levels
of battery life now if you're somebody
that really pushes the graphics i tested
out geekbench and blender and in
geekbench we normally score about 26
400 and we have a peak of 11.2 watts
with an average about 3.42 this tests a
lot of different tasks a lot of which
don't max out the gpu it's running
really efficiently and when we enabled a
low power mode our peak was 7.74
with an average of under 2 watts so over
70 percent less power being used and the
score barely dropped to 22
1448
that is only 19
less graphics performance while using 72
percent less power on average which is
insane now blender already uses barely
any power just under 5 watts i think
they have a lot more software
optimization to do these systems to get
a lot faster but switching to low power
mode it used about 79
less power there and in terms of
rendering our bmw test with the gpu it
took two minutes and 45 seconds instead
of 2 minutes and 15 seconds almost 2
minutes and 16 seconds so it took about
20 longer while using almost 80 less
power and with this whole render it
literally didn't even drop the battery
percentage by one percent so there you
guys go the true
amazing champ awesome part of the m2
chip are the efficiency cores but it is
a shame that apple isn't really making
the best use of them because in daily
use the battery ratings are very similar
compared to before and that is because
when you do end up doing something
opening an application something that
could use a cpu wiri shows high
frequencies that use a lot more power in
order to get those gains the apple
advertised on stage and truly we have
those performance gains
but
if they wanted to tone it down just a
little bit they would have gotten much
better battery life than b4 but of
course they do need to kind of compete
with their m1 chip so the efficiency
cores are amazing and if you want your
macbook air the m2 to run super cool
have insane battery life while still
giving you better performance than a
windows laptop go ahead and try this out
for yourself i think you'll be very
surprised or at least if you find
yourself in a situation where your
battery is very low you can't plug in
make sure to enable that because it will
still run very well
there you guys go if you guys enjoy
videos like these please click that
subscribe button above we would greatly
appreciate it check out one of those
great videos right over there this one
max and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]